ja so erster tag der haushaltsberatungen
hier und wir haben die ersten 1 pläne
gehört den letzten einzelplan heute das
wird derjenige sein für digitales und
verkehr und die fachpolitiker die
haushaltspolitiker die wechseln und sie
sehen die zuständigen minister die haben
hier noch ein kurzes gespräch steffi
lemke ist jetzt sozusagen mit ihrem
einzelplan durch und volker wissing den
sie neben ihr sehen der bundesminister
für digitales und verkehr der wird jetzt
hier gleich seinen einzelplan vorstellen
ja es ist der drittgrößte posten und der
größte investitionshaushalt im haushalt
2022 und volker wissing denen sie hier
sehen der hat ja auch die ersten 100
tage als minister hinter sich vergangene
woche war ja sozusagen stichtag wenn man
möchte für diese bundesregierung die
ersten 100 tage im amt und die ersten
100 tage hier für volker wissing doch
einige probleme und krisen bereit fehlen
des breitband investitionsstau marode
drücken und zuletzt da stand er in der
kritik beispielsweise des landes berlin
das ihm vorwirft zu viele sonderzüge mit
menschen aus der ukraine mit
geflüchteten nach berlin zu leiten und
keine verständigung mit der bahn zu
erreichen über umleitungen verteilung
das ist etwas besser geworden aber wie
gesagt es geht ja auch um seinen
einzelplan vor allem hören wir den
ministerrat frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich beginne mit einem dank einem dunk
aus tiefem herzen er gilt allen die seit
dem russischen angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine übermenschliches geleistet haben
und weiter leisten ich danke den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern der
deutschen bahn die sofort engagiert
geholfen haben als es darum ging
verzweifelte flüchtlinge in sicherheit
zu bringen und hilfsgüter zu
transportieren ich danke allen lkw
fahrerin und lkw fahrern die seit wochen
unter erschwerten bedingungen alles
daran setzen zu helfen
unsere versorgung sicherzustellen und
lieferketten aufrecht zu erhalten
man danke auf der bundeswehr den
sozialen diensten den unzähligen
helferinnen und helfern und allen
freiwilligen die allesamt anpacken und
das entsetzliche leid der flüchtenden
ländern diese solidarität diese
hilfsbereitschaft diese tatkraft sie
berühren und machen mut und
meine damen und herren genau den mut
brauchen wir denn die herausforderungen
vor denen wir stehen sind gigantisch
auch mein haus tut alles um die
beförderung der geflüchteten zu
organisieren und bei der logistik von
hilfsgütern zu unterstützen und zugleich
müssen wir unsere zukunftsthemen weiter
vorantreiben klimaschutz digitalisierung
und moderne mobilität und die
vergangenen wochen haben gezeigt dass es
möglich zu packen und zuversicht handeln
und herzlichkeit transformation und
teilhabe der haushalt über den wir heute
reden ist dafür eine sehr gute grundlage
bietet verlässlichkeit in unsicheren
zeiten und ermöglicht gleichzeitig
transformationen und fortschritt rund
21,9 milliarden euro sind alleine für
investitionen vorgesehen davon rund 19,5
milliarden in die verkehrsinfrastruktur
schienenwege brücken straßen tunnel
wasserstraßen mobilfunk und
breitbandnetze das sind lebensnotwendige
adern für wirtschaft und gesellschaft
das alles steht meine damen und herren
für mobilität für transport und
kommunikation sind ganz wesentliche
grundbedürfnisse eines modernen sozialen
gemeinwesens und unserer heutigen
investitionen in die infrastruktur sind
investitionen in unsere zukunft es sind
investitionen in unseren künftigen
wohlstand in den zusammenhalt der
gesellschaft in ein land das seinen
menschen chancen bietet
der erhalt der infrastruktur ist ein
generationenvertrag es ist die aufgabe
unserer generation die infrastruktur zu
erhalten die unsere mütter und väter
aufgebaut haben es ist unsere aufgabe
der nächsten generation eine
infrastruktur zu übergeben die ihr ein
leben in wohlstand
freiheit ermöglicht genau so wie uns das
ermöglicht wurde und infrastruktur darf
nicht in jahren sie muss in generationen
gedacht werden deshalb investieren wir
beispielsweise
9,4 milliarden euro in die
klimafreundliche schiene und damit
deutlich mehr als in die straße wir
wollen unsere mobilität so schnell wie
möglich klimaneutral gestalten das ist
eine unserer verpflichtungen gegenüber
künftigen generationen und daran
arbeiten werden
wir werden deshalb auch den öpnv und den
radverkehr auf rekordniveau unterstützen
wir treiben außerdem den ausbau von
ladesäulen voran und unterstützen das
verlagern von güterverkehr auf die
schiene und auf die wasserstraße und
meine damen und herren ein schwerpunkt
ist natürlich auch die digitalisierung
die mittel für automatisierte und
vernetztes fahren etwa haben wir um rund
48 millionen auf mehr als 64 millionen
euro erhöht der ansatz für die
potenziale der digitalen wirtschaft wird
sogar verdoppelt der ansatz für den
breitbandausbau wird zunächst mit den
ausgaben resten im einzelplan 12 bedient
die wir abbauen und dann 20 26 werden
zusätzlich 334,5 millionen euro
investiert dieser haushalt er steht für
einen grundsätzlichen wechsel ein
wechsel weg vom immer mehr hin zum immer
effektiver wir wollen sicherstellen dass
das geld dahin fließt wo damit der
größte nutzen für unsere gesellschaft
erzielt werden kann deshalb prüfen wir
sehr genau welche unterstützung und
welche förderprogramme gut und richtig
waren welche wir weiterführen die mir
und welche wir aufstocken und welche
nicht das haben wir schon mit unseren
eckpunkten für die gigabit strategie in
den gesprächen mit den ländern bei der
sonderfahrt zum öpnv und mit unserem
brücken gipfel um den zukunftspaket für
leistungsfähige autobahnbrücken
angestoßen gleiches haben wir auch im
masterplan ladeinfrastruktur vor denen
wir in kürze präsentieren werden überall
gilt wir wollen gezielt fördern und
investieren dem engen austausch mit
denjenigen die damit arbeiten und davon
profitieren sollen die menschen sollen
spüren es geht voran und zwar schnell
und diese regierung geht
verantwortungsvoll mit dem geld der
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler um
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
viel vor wir unterstützen den umstieg
hin zu klimafreundlicher mobilität und
zwar in allen verkehrsbereichen an land
auf dem wasser und in der luft wir
investieren massiv in die digitale
infrastruktur wir modernisieren und
digitalisieren
wir sorgen dafür dass
infrastrukturprojekte schneller
vorankommen eine gute anbindung gerade
im ländlichen raum gewährleistet ist wir
stärken die gesamte infrastruktur wir
machen sie krisenfest der vorliegende
haushalt steht für verlässlichkeit und
zuversicht die wir alle brauchen klar
ist eine leistungsfähige infrastruktur
ermöglicht eine
klimafreundliche mobilität vor allem
aber auch wirtschaftswachstum
investitionen sichere arbeitsplätze
einen funktionierenden sozialstaat und
damit versetzt sie uns überhaupt erst in
die lage dass wir menschen in not helfen
können wir müssen vieles weiter
entwickeln gleichzeitig auch vieles neu
entwickeln und neue oder neu aufbauen
wir müssen heute dafür sorgen dass die
mobilität der zukunft attraktiv ist
keine die vor allem einschränkungen und
verzicht bedeutet sondern neue chancen
und angebote bereithält dieser haushalt
ist das fundament auf dem wir die
mobilität der zukunft aufbauen wollen
vielen dank
nichts weniger verspricht volker wissing
der bundesminister für digitales und
verkehr größten investitionshaushalt
aber gerade im bereich verkehr gibt es
einen e mails sind investitionsstau
bislang allein 2021 blieb jede fünfte
euro der für investitionen vorgesehen
war liegen frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
wissen sind jetzt als digitalen minister
ziemlich genau 100 tage im amt wir
hätten jetzt in der zeit nicht erwartet
dass sie die welt retten oder den
letzten weiler mit glasfaser erschließen
wir haben noch nicht mal erwartet dass
in der zeit eine digitale strategie
vorlegen
was wir aber erwartet hätte wäre dass
sich die ampel in den ersten 100 tagen
zumindest darauf einig wer für was
zuständig ist wir haben im januar 62
konkrete fragen zu digitalen themen an
die bundesregierung gestellt wir haben
gestern die antwort erhalten und es ist
im wesentlichen eine antwort über die
interne verteilung der zuständigkeiten
finden noch regierungsinterne
abstimmungen statt ich habe den satz so
oft gelesen dass ihnen schon fast
auswendig konnten meine damen und herren
das wäre ja alles kein problem wenn wir
heute nicht den haushalt für 2022
beraten würden denn alles was nicht im
haushalt für 22 steht wird 22 nicht
passieren und er wissen sie hatten viele
gute ideen im koalitionsvertrag die
nehmer als beispiel digital budget
besteht in diesem haushalt nicht drin
warum es war doch ihr spruch digital
first bedenken second machen sie doch
einfach mal
als digitalen minister haben sie aber
bereits und das muss man fairerweise
dazusagen am tag 99 einen ersten
inhaltlichen punkt gemacht sie haben
denn die eckpunkte für ihre gigabit
strategie vorgestellt
exklusiv den sie aus der großen
netzbetreiber
also ich hätte es besser gefunden sie
hätten am tag 98 ist im ausschuss
vorgestellt zu dem zeitpunkt hatten sie
nämlich die grünen auf die tagesordnung
gesetzt und ihre staatssekretärin hat
original eine ganze stunde lang die
auskunft über ihre pläne verweigert mit
der begründung
der minister müsse das zuerst mit dem
unternehmen besprechen bevor in den
bundestag kommt jeder so wie er mag aber
meine damen und herren die inhalte
die inhalte der der die eckpunkte liegen
in der zwischenzeit vor es ist inhalt
über dem der reden kann das möchte ich
auch gern tun wir hätten viele punkte in
den eckpunkten ähnlich formuliert wie
sie
digitalisierung der
genehmigungsverfahren gigabit grundbuch
einsatz alternative verleger verfahren
unterstützung der kommunen das geht
alles in die richtige richtung aber wenn
sie es im ausschuss vorgestellt hätten
hätte ich bei ein paar punkten die hand
gewonnen und ich nenne jetzt mal 3 der
erste punkt sie setzen voll auf den
privaten wirtschaftlichen ausbau ohne
aber zu wissen wer diese investoren und
fonds eigentlich sind und was sie wollen
und ob es tatsächlich wie alles das in
den nächsten jahren 50 milliarden euro
in die infrastruktur in deutschland
investieren würden wenn sie es tun dann
ist es gut dann begrüße ich es absolut
aber im moment traurig den power points
noch nicht der zweite
der zweite punkt ich komme gleich dazu
der zweite punkt ist sie wollen
bestehende kabelnetze überbauen wenn
ihre ziele so wie sie beschrieben haben
aufgeht werden 2025 mindestens 20
prozent der haushalte in deutschland
zwei gigabit anschlüsse zur auswahl
haben glasfaser oder und kamen das wird
vor allem in den städten der fall sein
ich würde es für besser empfinden wenn
sie sich ein ziel setzen würden das in
stadt und land zumindest jeder einen hut
der dritte punkt ist und jetzt komme ich
zu den neuen markterkundungsverfahren
potenzialanalysen und so weiter sie
vergeuden zu viel zeit mit neuen
eckpunkten mit strategien mit der neuen
förderinstrumenten mit neuen
förderverfahren
ich prognostiziere ihnen bis sie ihr
neues förderprogramm am laufen haben
wird es mitte 20 23 sind das bedeutet
dass der erste von der ampel gefördert
die glasfaseranschluss frühestens ende
2024 ans netz gehen kann ich weiß und
die chinesischen vor mir sie werden sich
trotzdem
2025 hier an dieses pools stellen und
eine erfolgsbilanz verkünden das werde
aber nicht die erfolgsbilanz meetings
und es wird die erfolgsbilanz chancen
der minister
hat in seiner zeit
9,4 milliarden euro für den
glasfaserausbau fest zugesagt
2400 projekte sind auf dem weg
2,7 millionen anschlüssen werden in den
nächsten jahren damit entstehen
herr wissing
sie sind der auch verkehrsminister ich
probiere es nochmal damit geben sie mehr
gas ja da haben sie uns an ihrer seite
aber würden sie den bestehenden
fördermodell nicht ab und für die
kollegen von der fdp muss mich erst
gewöhnen
setzen da sitzen denn ich hätte ja auch
kollegen haben plakate bevor sie sich
zurückhalten wenn du hast alles steril
zeiten second das wäre mal ein schritt
probieren sie es mal mit herzlichen dank
für die technologie aktion war dazu
sprecher für digitale hatte moniert dass
volker wissing vergangene woche seine
gigabit strategie mit der rückseite
väter sind inzwischen liegen dem
ausschuss volker wissing hat diese
eckpunkte wie für die gigabit strategie
vorgelegt und den meniskus die hälfte
der haushalte in den nächsten drei
jahren mit glasfaseranschluss versorgen
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin
war ich schließe mich den den
danksagungen des bundesministers an
nicht nur für den transport der bahn
innerhalb der bundesrepublik deutschland
für geflüchtete in unserem land sondern
auch für den für den materialtransport
in ukraine herzlichen dank nochmal
ausdrücklich auch an dieser stelle
ich möchte meiner rede vier schwerpunkte
zum abtransport aufrufen erstens wir
müssen die mobilitäts wende vorantreiben
2 wir müssen co2 konsequenter einsparen
und liebe kollegen kollegen sicherheit
im wandel bedeutet natürlich auch wir
müssen mobilität sozial transformieren
mobilität sozial gerecht gestalten und
viertens wir müssen natürlich in zeiten
dieses krieges in der ukraine sehen ob
das auch bedeuten für einzelplan 12 wir
müssen angesichts unserer derzeitigen
außenpolitische herausforderung auch zum
beispiel bei die resilienz unserer
infrastruktur nachdenken und wie sich
das im einzelplan selber im detail
darstellt ihr kollege und kollegen in
den anstehenden zum haushalt 22 ist das
thema menschengemachter thema
klimawandel zu recht das überragende
thema es geht um unseren planeten ein
drittel aller co2 emissionen entfallen
auf dem mobilitätsbereich wir müssen in
diesem zusammenhang über unser
mobilitätsverhalten sprechen wir müssen
über unsere antriebstechnik sprechen und
wir müssen
über das thema welche energien wir dafür
nutzen ganz neu denken für uns
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
ist die frage der sozialen ausgestaltung
der mobilitäts wenn er eine frage der
gerechtigkeit
dieser transformationsprozess darf keine
verlierer produzieren das kann auch eine
gefahr für die stabilität der demokratie
werden die energiepreise dürfen nicht
die neuen brotpreise werden
mobilitätsbedarf kein sozialen abstieg
befördern
wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass im 21 jahrhundert die
mobilität nicht zu einem luxusgut
mobilität muss für alle
einkommensgruppen bezahlbar bleiben
deshalb ist unser staat besonders in der
verantwortung
ausreichend bezahlbare
mobilitätsangebote angebote gehirn zur
daseinsvorsorge deshalb ist
verkehrspolitik auch immer sozialpolitik
auch hier müssen wir denken wenn wir in
den kommenden wochen in den einzelnen
titeln im einzelplan zwölf arbeiten
putins krieg bedeutet für den einzelplan
12 wir müssen identifizieren welche
maßnahmen die für unsere infrastruktur
ergreifen müssen um der neuen
außenpolitischen bedrohungssituation im
ernstfall gewachsen zu sein
kollege und kollegen der von uns oder
von der bundesregierung uns vorgelegte
entwurf macht einen guten ersten
eindruck wesentliche aspekte die wir im
koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten haben sind zutreffend
adressiert gemeinsam werden wir in
diesem haus in den anstehenden
beratungen
schauen welche feinjustierungen aus
sicht des haushalts gesetzgebers
angezeigt sein der minister da struck
gesetz wird vor dem einzelplan zwölft
nicht haltbaren seien sich dessen sicher
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen vor die
sich im punkte sind mir wichtig weil sie
von strategischer bedeutung für unsere
zukunft sind erster in den kommenden
jahren müssen wir den schwerpunkt auf
den erhalt unserer infrastruktur setzen
unser land verfügt über eine gut
ausgebaute infrastruktur das ist richtig
machen wir uns jedoch nichts vor um
allein die vorhandene infrastruktur in
schuss zu halten sind gewaltige
anstrengungen erforderlich
bundesminister wissing hat zu recht
einen autobahn
rücken gipfel
organisiert und dazu eingeladen das ist
richtig und wichtig das ist jedoch ein
erster gipfel auf denen noch
wahrscheinlich weitere folgen müssen der
zustand unserer eisenbahnbrücken ist
nicht besser die leistungs und
finanzierungsvereinbarung mit der
deutschen bahn bietet keinen
ausreichenden rahmen um die sanierung
dieser eisenbahnbrücken sicherzustellen
dafür sind die einzelnen brücken zu
teuer wir brauchen auch ein gipfel für
unsere wasserstraßen und unsere
schleusen die stiefmütterliche
behandlung von wasserstraßen gegenüber
schiene und straße gehört der
vergangenheit an das muss aufhören die
leistungsfähigkeit unserer wasserstraßen
ist für unsere klimaziele von
strategischer bedeutung
wir brauchen einen fahrplan wie der
sanierungsstau bei unseren wasserstraßen
abgebaut wird dazu gehört auch das thema
schleusen
eine zweite strategische weichenstellung
die dämonisierung modernisierung und
digitalisierung der
verkehrsinfrastruktur mit der
digitalisierung können wir mehr
mobilität auch unser bereits vorhandenen
infrastruktur organisieren insbesondere
digitalisierung der schiene verspricht
signifikante kapazität steigen das ist
mal eine gute nachricht eine weitere
wichtige weichenstellung ist drittens
das thema schnittstellen dabei geht es
um die vernetzung einzelner
verkehrsträger insbesondere im bereich
güterverkehr
wir müssen die wechselseitigen übergänge
zwischen straße schiene und wasser
schaffen das ist zum einen eine frage
der infrastruktur und die als
schnittstelle bereitgestellt wird das
ist aber auch die frage von klugar
förderung dazu gehörten ermöglichen das
war mal häfen man sich die zwischenfrage
zu lassen von der art die fraktion
rechts liegen dass wir die
weiterentwicklung des rpnv
die weiterentwicklung pnv ist für die
gerechte ausgestaltung der mobilitäts
wende von strategischer bedeutung wir
sollten die länder bei der schaffung
eines attraktiven angebots für den psv
unterstützen dann steigen auch mehr
menschen um dafür bieten die anstehenden
verhandlungen zur anhebung der
regionalisierungsmittel einen guten 5
was mir besonders wichtig ist mobilität
im ländlichen raum dazu gehört auch die
bessere pnv entschließen
und demand angebote könnte aber auch
eine rolle spielen 6 wir sollten auch
bei unseren anstrengungen zu
alternativen antrieben die
elektromobilität wasserstoff antriebe
oder alternative kraftstoffe nicht
nachlassen in hamburg forscht airbus am
klimaneutralen flugzeug das mit
wasserstoff angetrieben wird wir müssen
deshalb dafür sorgen dass wenn dieses
flugzeug mal fertig ist wie auf
flughäfen haben die mit wasserstoff
ausgerüstet und ihre infrastruktur und
schließlich drittens ist es wichtig dass
wir die chancen der digitalisierung
nutzen wir müssen sicherstellen dass
transformationsprozesse
nicht an unsere stadtgrenzen haltmachen
es gilt den breitbandausbau auch in
ländlichen regionen voranzutreiben wir
müssen den online-zugang
verwaltungsdienstleistungen
zugang zu verwaltungsdienstleistungen
weiter verbessern die beratung ist
einzelplan 12 ist noch ein gutes stück
arbeit ich freue mich auf den intensiven
austausch und die beratung bis in den
mitte mai und bedanke mich hier raus
und wird entsprechend den beratungen zu
diesem einzelplan unter anderem
mitwirken
markus pröll hat das wort für die fw
fraktion
er ist ebenfalls mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
steuereinnahmen und verkehrshaushalt der
wunsch der grünen aus den neunzigern der
liter benzin bürger fünfmal kosten hat
sich inzwischen so gut wie erfüllt war
teilweise über zwei euro 30 liegt der
literpreis was nah an die fünf mark
herankommt das internationale einflüsse
wie der ukraine krieg den massiven
preisanstieg nur teilweise begründen
zeigt der blick zu unseren polnischen
nachbarn wo diesel und benzin zu
deutlich niedrigeren preisen zu bekommen
sind während die polnische regierung
ihre bürger über steuersenkungen
entlastet bleiben die steuerschrauben in
deutschland weiter unerbittlich fest
angezogen wir fordern sofort weg mit der
co2 abgabe pendlerpauschale erhöhen
runter mit den albtraum steuern
treibstoffe müssen finanzierbar bleiben
kommen wir zum größten
investitionshaushalt des bundes dem
haushalt für digitales und verkehr
investitionshaushalt heißt investieren
und da fangen die probleme in ihrem
entwurf herr minister wissen bereits an
hohe ausgaben reste sind auch in diesem
jahr die realität aber investitionen nur
auf dem papier audi nicht realisiert
werden sind augenwischerei und bringen 0
fortschritt unsere infrastruktur ist
stark belastet folgerichtig muss die
substanzerhaltung auch 2022 im fokus
stehen die eigner brücken gipfel vor
wenigen wochen hat gezeigt wie groß die
aufgabe bei der sanierung der
infrastruktur wirklich sind abertausende
marode brücken sprechen eine deutliche
sprache
unsere straßen entwickeln fast 80
prozent des verkehrs ab und da muss ich
das auch bei den investitionen und dem
erhalt im haushaltsplan widerspiegeln
herr minister
viel zu tun gibt es auch bei der
aufklärung der berater affäre der
deutschen bahn der bundesrechnungshof
hat in seinen berichten auf die zustände
hingewiesen und in diesem zusammenhang
von politischer landschaftspflege
gesprochen hier endlich aufzuräumen ist
mehr als über aufwändig
global aufgestellt sollte sie sein die
bahn was zu hunderten beteiligungen
weltweit geführt hat und wenn man mal
von der einen großen logistiktochter
absieht wie geht es eigentlich den
anderen beteiligungen nur mal zur
erinnerung seit ihrer privatisierung hat
die bahn 32 milliarden euro schulden
angehäuft was wir brauchen ist eine
rückführung der deutschen bahn auf ihr
kerngeschäft eisenbahn in deutschland
wirtschaftlich und zuverlässig
durchzuführen
deutschland hinter der digital politikum
viele jahre hinterher die unzureichende
breitbandversorgung
polizei bundeswehr und
katastrophenschutz mit veralteter
digitaltechnik sind die traurigen
ergebnisse dieser politik so herr wissen
kann und darf es nicht weitergehen ich
danke
[Applaus]
markus buhl für die afg fraktionen erst
mit dem haushaltsausschuss und
in den einzelplan beratungen oder
kommen die fachpolitiker zu wort aber
dann natürlich auch die haushälter die
dann die posten in den parlamentarischen
beratungen noch mal einzeln durchgehen
jetzt für die grünen die haushälterin
paula potter
die war volker wissing liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich danke insbesondere
volker wissing und metin hakverdi für
die ich glaube der aktuellen situation
in der wir uns auch mit der
verkehrsinfrastruktur
befinden deutlich angemesseneren worte
ich möchte auch gleich mit dem dank an
schließen aber glauben sie mir noch mal
kurz in ganz kleinen blick
zurückzuwerfen
vor ungefähr einem jahr sind wir in der
bundesrepublik in den wahlkampf
gestartet und es gab einen vertreter der
union der damals immer wieder die
erzählung ausgepackt hat das jetzt bald
die goldenen zwanziger kommen die
goldenen zwanziger panama ist vorbei
alles wird wieder gut immer noch diese
überzeugung dass es diese eine krise
gibt und dann ist die vorbei und dann
ist erst mal wieder gut und wir sehen
jetzt dass hätte nicht besser sein
können wir leben nicht mehr in der zeit
wo es diese eine krise gibt und dann ist
gut sondern wir leben in der zeit wo die
eine krise nicht endet und die nächste
noch dazukommt und die andere auch
weiter besteht wer es nicht zwei oder
drei wir haben jetzt über vier krisen
auf einmal zu bewältigen und es spielt
sich auch alles im bereich der
verkehrsinfrastruktur ab auch die ganzen
konflikte die da passieren wenn ihr
jetzt herr wissing hat angesprochen
metin hakverdi hass angesprochen denn
wir schauen was alleine gerade bei
busunternehmen aber auch auf der schiene
geleistet wird beim transport von
flüchtlingen beim transport von gütern
aber zum beispiel auf dem wir schauen
sie in belarus gerade schienen sabotiert
werden damit eben russische truppen
darüber nicht unterstützt werden können
wenn wir uns anschauen aber auch
stichwort klimakrise wie gerade und man
muss das verurteilen wenn es andere
menschen gefährdet aber wie menschen
inzwischen in diesem land zunehmend so
verzweifelt sind das die autobahn
blockieren weil einfach zunehmend
menschen verzweifeln weil wieder alsfeld
gesellschaft ja und ja die klimaziele
reisen insbesondere auch im
verkehrssektor und natürlich auch
dritter punkt digitalisierung
was hätte in diesem land auch in der
korona krise was hätte hier alles besser
laufen können denn wenn ihr
funktionieren das beste für
digitalisierung schon letztes jahr schon
vorher gehabt hätte
ich das nicht ich sag das nicht alles
weil ich noch mal aufzählen möchte wie
wichtig verkehrsinfrastruktur ist ich
sage dass bei verkehrsinfrastruktur in
der aktuellen zeit auch mit darüber
entscheidet wie leistungsfähig sie ist
wie zuverlässig sie ist das mit darüber
entscheidet ob wir diese krisen gut
gelöst bekommen oder nicht und deswegen
ist es so fatal in welchen zustand wir
diese infrastruktur übernehmen von der
vorgängerregierung
es ist kein geheimnis dass grüne und fdp
und spd nicht in allen fragen der
verkehrspolitik immer sofort einer
meinung sind aber da wo wir uns einig
sind das ist dass wir jetzt eine neue
ernsthaftigkeit in der verkehrspolitik
brauchen in diesen zeiten wir brauchen
keine symbolpolitik mehr wir brauchen
keine regionalpolitik mehr in diesen
zeiten kann man sich nicht mehr in das
verstecken in diesen zeiten muss man
trainieren schießen bahnhöfe saniert und
es klingt nicht das ist nicht so fashion
das hat nicht so viel glamour aber das
ist das was diese zeiten von uns
verlangen
und wurde uns auch einig sind
wir uns auch einig sind ist dass wir
verkehrspolitik und
verkehrsinfrastruktur auch
haushalterisch abbilden müssen für alle
menschen in diesem land nicht nur für
autofahrer in einem nicht nur in einem
bestimmten bundesland und nicht nur im
ländlichen raum oder nur in der stadt
sondern wir brauchen
verkehrsinfrastruktur die funktioniert
für die menschen im norden dieses landes
im westen dieses landes im süden und im
osten dieses landes und da gibt es
unterschiedliche bedürfnisse und wir
brauchen auch verkehrsinfrastruktur die
funktioniert für menschen im ländlichen
raum und auch in den städten in den
städten wo es zu zug gibt und wo der op
en v mitwachsen muss wenn die
einwohnerzahlen steigen das brauchen wir
in der verkehrskommission
ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz auf die
brücken eingehen weil autobahn sind der
es nicht das leib- und magenthema von
grünen aber wir stehen natürlich auch
ganz klar dazu dass diese
autobahnbrücken saniert werden müssen
und dass sie überhaupt saniert werden
müssen sie hätten ja eigentlich genug zu
tun mit den ganzen krisen die wir jetzt
zu bewältigen haben alle hände voll zu
tun aber stattdessen müssen wir
zusätzlich noch die hausaufgaben machen
die in den letzten jahren liegen
gelassen wurden und das ist deswegen
auch super toll weil wir das jetzt in
der situation muss mit
baukostensteigerung mit gestörten
lieferketten das ist die denkbar
ungünstigste situation um das alles noch
nachholen zu müssen
das wird ein großer kraftakt vor allem
aufgrund der gleichzeitigkeit hoffe ich
das tor in kraft gleichzeitig hätten
wahrscheinlich vergessen ihre maske
wieder auszusetzen
wenn hier in der ärzte entspricht
bitteschön
ich glaube das wird ein unglaublich
großer kraft hat gerade auch
haushalterisch und ich bin da ganz metin
hakverdi und wahrscheinlich auch gleich
bei frank schäffler wenn ich sage dieser
haushalt wird das parlament nicht so
verlassen wie hier reingekommen ist aber
ich glaube das was wir am ende dieses
kraftakts erreicht haben müssen und auch
anders als die vorgängerregierung ist
eine infrastruktur die bleibt statt
prügelt ist auch eine infrastruktur wo
die menschen sicher sein können dass
wenn sie von a nach b gelangen müssen
dass sie dabei nicht automatisch
gleichzeitig im planeten schädigen ist
eine infrastruktur die krisenfest ist
und die auch funktioniert ganz schneit
und wenn es stürmt und wenn aufgrund des
klimawandels die klimatischen
bedingungen das wetter häufiger verrückt
spielt und das ist am ende auch eine
infrastruktur die krisenfest ist und die
menschen zuverlässig zusammenbringt
statt sie unnötig aufzuhalten
insbesondere auch im bereich der
digitalisierung vielen dank
[Applaus]
90 kunden ja auch nun hat sie das thema
brückensanierung angesprochen war er
hier schon häufiger thema in der
aussprache zu diesem einzelplan der
sanierungsstau betreffe so sagt das
ministerium
4000 brücken autobahn und bundesstraße
victor perli für die linke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
nach zwölf jahren csu im
verkehrsministerium nach ramsauer
dobrindt und scheuern nach einer politik
voller pleiten und skandale dachte man
eigentlich jetzt kann es nur besser
werden
doch weit gefehlt
bereits der polizei ums vertrag ist bei
ihm verkehr und digitalem eine einzige
enttäuschung
passend dazu
passend dazu kann das größte lob
ausgerechnet von ex-verkehrsminister
scheuer der neue koalitionsvertrag
könnte von mir sein sagte er ich hatte
im letzten jahren wirklich selten
übereinstimmung mit herrn steuer aber da
hat er recht die verkehrspolitik von spd
von früheren fdp ist wer sozial gerecht
noch klimafreundlich
und das setzt sich jetzt hier in einem
wirklich ambitionslose haushaltsentwurf
vor dabei haben wir große
herausforderungen
mobilität wird immer teurer das belastet
immer mehr menschen die ticketpreise bei
bus und bahn steigen seit jahren stark
an und jetzt sind auch die benzinpreise
explodiert weil ölkonzerne dem schlimmen
kriegen der ukraine für extraprofite
ausnutzen die ampelkoalition hat darauf
immer noch keine antwort wie es geht
zeigt neuseeland dort hat die regierende
sozialistische partei
gerade die preise für den öffentlichen
nahverkehr halbiert die fahrpreise
halbiert und die steuern auf benzin
gesenkt liebe sozialdemokraten und
grünen findet ihr nicht auch dass eine
bessere idee wäre als über 1 8 100
milliarden euro für atombombe und für
kriegswaffen zur verfügung zu stellen
seit jahren wird in sonntagsreden eine
bessere bahn versprochen dass die busse
häufiger fahren und günstiger werden
viele menschen wünschen sich dass man
sie dann mal ihr auto stehen lassen
könnten es wäre auch gut fürs klima
warum gibt es kein 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögens für bus und bahn warum
gibt es eine bundesinitiative für ein
jahr das switch von 365 euro also für 1
euro pro tag bei unseren nachbarn in
luxemburg ist der öffentliche nahverkehr
sogar kostenfrei im haushaltsentwurf der
koalition steht bei den zuschüssen des
bundes für den nahverkehr kein einziger
euro mehr als entwurf dem entwurf der
eigenen regierung damit fällt der
haushaltsentwurf sogar den
koalitionsvertrag zurück das ist eine
einzige enttäuschung und damen und
herren
die position behauptet und auch der
minister das nie getan dass die
koalition jetzt mehr in china ist die
straße investieren würde aber das stimmt
nicht sie haben bei den straßen einfach
mal so eine milliarde euro
planungskosten rausgerechnet aber es ist
uns aufgefallen und übrigens auch der
allianz pro schiene und das ist ein
finde ich sehr sehr schädiger
taschenspielertrick der übrigens auch
zeigt dass sie einen sehr schlechten
finanzplan vor gericht haben dann müsste
man sowas ja nicht machen irgendwie
jetzt taschenspielertricks hier
vorzulegen ist eine einzige enttäuschung
dieser haushaltsentwurf aber ich glaube
spritzen auf die beratungen vielen dank
victor perli linke im haushaltsausschuss
haushaltsberatung
die wird mannschaft das sollte es dann
vor allem wenn das parlament doch noch
einige änderungswünsche hat jetzt hat
die fdp noch mal das wort hier der
hausherr frank schäffler
minister frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren minister
wissing hat finde ich
völlig richtig dargestellt welches große
engagement in der gesellschaft
im zuge der flüchtlingskrise und der
ukraine krieges da ist da müssen wir
wirklich als gesellschaft dankbar sein
dass das in deutschland eigentlich sogar
ein ganz europa möglich ist wenn man
sieht was sie polen was die tschechen
was die bulgaria bulgaren und andere
machen das ist wirklich ganz ganz großes
kino und da können wir eigentlich stolz
sein was da aktuell auch geschaffen wird
deshalb
deshalb will ich
auf die etwas negative konnotation
meines kollegen rainer brandl erst mal
eingehen weil ich finde er plante den
oppositions modus schon nach 100 tagen
direkt einzuschalten obwohl man
eigentlich
obwohl man eigentlich vier
verkehrsminister gestellt hat als union
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt schon
ziemlich peinlich also von den
4 milliarden die in diesem haushalt
veranschlagt wurden diesem bislang nicht
ausgegeben worden weil sie es nicht
geschafft haben die auf die straße zu
bringen auf die schiene zu bringen und
auf die wasserstraße zu bringen und im
digitalen bereich sind eine milliarde
liegen geblieben weil sie auch nicht in
der lage waren das auf die straße zu
bringen also sie tragen doch
hauptsächlich die verantwortung dafür
dass wir bei diesen wichtigen themen
über die wir tagtäglich reden sei es die
digitale infrastruktur sei es die
brücken sei es die brücken im
schienenverkehr und sei es eben die
wasserstraße tragen sie die
verantwortung und dass sie sich so
hinstellen wir werden jetzt alles besser
werden müsste weil sie schon ganz gut
waren das glaube ich nicht besonders
glaubwürdig wenn man da die
vergangenheit betrachtet also kehren sie
gefälligst erst mal vor der eigenen
haustür bevor sie anderen vorwürfe
machen wir haben relativ ehrgeizige
ziele aufgeschrieben im
koalitionsvertrag wir wollen die
fahrgastzahlen im
schienenverkehr verdoppeln wir wollen
der güterverkehr auf der bahntrasse um
25 prozent erhöhen wir wollen 75 des
schienennetzes elektrifizieren wir
wollen deutschland zum leitmarkt für
alternative antriebe und kraftstoffe
arten entwickeln und beim breitband und
mobilfunk ausbau wollen der weltspitze
sein
das setzt wiederum voraus dass man auch
eine gewisse prioritätensetzung macht
wahrscheinlich werden wir um es auf die
bahn einmal zu reduzieren nicht alles
auf einmal erreichen sondern da muss es
prioritäten gegeben und ich meine wir
müssen die prioritäten darauf setzen was
wir jetzt kurz und mittelfristig
erreichen können und das muss das ziel
dieser koalition sein und dafür werde
ich mich einsetzen ich glaube ist
nämlich notwendig dass wir uns auf diese
kurz mittelfristigen fragen
konzentrieren wenn wir das nicht tun
dann laufen uns die investition die die
die die fragen der
stand setzungen und der fragen der
erneuerung von schienen und straßen
weiter fort inzwischen haben die bahn
haben die brücken einen
altersdurchschnitt von 74 jahren und in
vielen bereichen das halte ich ehrlich
gesagt für einen großen
investitionsbedarf in der nahen zukunft
und deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
wir hier in diesem bereich schneller
werden und die bahn muss vor allem auch
schneller werden die bahn muss
pünktlicher werden die bahn muss
freundlicher werden sie muss mehr
dienstleister sein sie muss vor allem
auch was die was die erneuerung von
technik betrifft schneller werden da
muss mehr tempo kommen und ich glaube
das ist einer der großen
zukunftsaufgaben wir dürfen nicht
irgendwelche
zukunftsprojekte an die wand malen die
irgendwann mal kommen mögen sondern wir
müssen jetzt bei der bahn endlich
handeln ich glaube die menschen sind es
leid dass die deutsche bundesbahn im
wesentlichen dadurch auch auffällt dass
sie zu spät kommt und weil das
wagenmaterial zu alt ist oder weil die
digitalisierung der schiene immer noch
nicht vorankommt da müssen wir einfach
schneller werden und das ist glaube ich
eines der wichtigen dinge die wir
voranbringen wollen also wir wollen halt
deutsche bahn die qualität produziert
die service produziert die pünktlich ist
und dass in den mittelpunkt stellt und
vor allem dass sie teure
prestigeprojekte möglichst nicht angeht
sondern verbesserungen kurz und
mittelfristig dafür müssen wir die
mittel konzentrieren
in welchem des größten zustand die
autobahn sind das haben wir erfahren bei
den brücken wissen wir dass allein
nordwales vertrauen hat größere
autobahnbrücken inzwischen
marode sind und erneuert werden müssen
und deshalb glaube ich ist das eine der
wesentlichen aufgaben um die wir uns
kümmern wollen natürlich auch der
kombinierte verkehr zwischen schiene
wasserstraße lkw sein thema und das
werden wir in den haushaltsberatungen
jetzt in den nächsten wochen gemeinsam
in der koalitionsfraktion angehen vielen
dank
nur sechs schiffe für die fdp fraktion
aber die opposition hat natürlich auch
noch ein wort mitzureden
jetzt beispielsweise die cdu csu
fraktion und deren verkehrspolitischer
sprecher thomas bareiß ja sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen erlauben sie mir aufgrund der
aktuellen ereignisse eine kleine
bemerkung so wie heute hier im deutschen
bundestag im großen beraten auch viele
zu hause ihren kleinen haushalt und
haben eine große notwehr teilweise die
spritpreise die tägliche fahrt zur
arbeit nicht mehr lohnend sind und
teilweise die fahrt zum einkauf
erdrücken dort ich glaube dass die
großen themen der menschen vor ort tief
spritpreis derzeit sind und das haben
heute kein wort gehört haben ist er kein
wort zum thema der spritpreise der
energiepreise ich glaube hier brauchen
wir schnell auch eine ganz konkrete
antwort von ihnen eine konkrete antwort
der bundesregierung statt ewig lange
diskussionen die quellen sind wir
brauchen auch hier eine ganz konkrete
lösung für die menschen vor ort und
einen konkreten maßnahmenkatalog auch
aus ihrem haus meine sehr verehrten
damen herren
heute berät der deutsche bundestag den
bundeshaushalt verkehrshaushalt 2022
vieles von dem was sie genannt haben
deswegen ist uns wohl bekannt so
schlecht kann die verkehrspolitik der
letzten jahre nicht gewesen sein wenn
sie unsere projekte und die finanzierung
tage eins zu eins übernommen haben im
haushalt vor allem wollen sie kräftig
investieren auch das haben wir ihnen
vorgemacht wir begrüßen das was sie
teilweise vorgeschlagen haben denn
aufgrund der hohen bedeutung des
verkehrssektors für die menschen unsere
wirtschaft industrie in deutschland ist
eine gute mittelausstattung des
verkehrssektors unverzichtbar durch eine
norm mit zuschuss und zur fuchs die
prioritätensetzung und auch die
prinzipien erhalt vor neubau wurde
bereits letzten textur periode durch cdu
und csu die entscheidende grundlage für
die mobilität der zukunft in allen
sektoren gelegt bei schiene straße und
wasserstraße
meine damen und herren waren heute
morgen der bundesfinanzminister den
mittel aufwuchs für die schiene zu
besonders betont erfolgen hat wo sie
nochmals in erinnerung rufen dass die
cdu/csu war die bereits in der nächsten
wahlperiode mehr geld für schiene als
milchstraße zu früh gestellt hat meine
damen und herren und fortschritt oder
neuanfang ist also weniger vorhanden als
hier oftmals gesagt wird übrigens auch
im schienenpersonenverkehr hat die cdu
csu die forderung 2050 mehr als
verdreifacht meine sehr verehrten damen
und haben meinen die bestehenden krisen
die fachkräftemangel und die steigende
energiepreise lassen derzeit die preise
für die notwendigen ausbauten für den
großen deutschen tarifrechts 20.30
explodieren das betrifft vor allen
dingen auch die baugewerbe es wäre die
aufgabe gewesen dass diese entwicklungen
auch ergibt wird um die zielmarken für
den ausbau zu erhalten mit diesem
haushalt hätte es dazu ein klares
bekenntnis vom bundesverkehrsministerium
gebraucht jetzt ist zu erkennen dass die
dramatischen kostenanstieg nicht zu
finanzieren sind der haushalt
muss diese preissteigerung in rechnung
tragen sonst sind alle die schöne
buchungen luftschlösser die nicht
umsetzbar sind herr minister und die
steigenden energiepreisen legen gerade
auch die kleinen und die
mittelständische unternehmen im
verkehrsgewerbe mit niedrigen margen und
den auswirkungen der korona pandemie im
rücken geht es für bus und taxi nehmen
um nicht weniger als ihre nackte
existenz sei dann mit jedem tag den sie
mit ihren finanziellen zusagen warten
steht immer mehr unternehmen des ebv das
wasser bis zum hals
meine damen sie haben hohe ziele im
bereich der e mobilität
aber auch hier lassen sie wieder
antworten vermissen wir warten dass die
koalition die hohen mittelzuweisungen
für die ladeinfrastruktur
jahres fortsetzt und nehmen den
rechtlichen und politischen ins sondern
auch die finanziellen rahmenbedingungen
für den hochlauf der eu steht in den
zwanzig zu werden schafft für eine
sichere bezahlbare und klimafreundliche
braucht es aber auch einen tl die
offenen ansatz
wir brauchen immunität wir brauchen in
wasserstoff und wir brauchen zieht
ethische kraftstoffe zu
schnellstmöglichen reichen der flotten
grenzwerte und unserer klimaziele es
heißt wenn wir in deutschland 15
millionen elektrofahrzeuge bis 20.30
schaffen es werden immer noch 30
millionen fahrzeuge seines rechts auf
den deutschen straßen sein die ein co2
freundlichen kraftstoff brauchen sonst
wird ihre verkehrswende nicht aufgeben
sehr vertrauter
hinaus
nicht nur geld meine damen wir brauchen
auch in die verlässlichkeit beim
straßenbau bei
infrastruktur
bundesverkehrswegeplan und die kann es
nicht sein dass ford die grünen ständig
auf maßnahmen infrage stellen wenn ich
behaupte dass die maßnahmen noch geprüft
wird und sie vor ort hier bundestag
behaupten dass hier keine note brauchen
verlässliche bedingungen wir brauchen
einen klaren rahmen für die bundeswehr
geplant und es habe auch hier ein
glasfenster die 1000 straßenbauprojekte
vor 70 schienenprojekte und 24 war es
straßen auch hier brauche
verlässlichkeit und einen klaren
fahrplan ist nächsten jahr weitergeht
auch hier minister brauchen wir ihr glas
hatte sich der wirklichkeit und
langsamkeit nicht geben und die fragen
wir so dringend auch im bereich der
bundesverkehrswegeplan dass sie dank der
thomas bareiß für die cdu zur situation
der hat hier auch kritisiert dass vom
minister kein einziges wort kam zu einem
thema das die bürgerinnen und bürger
beschäftigt mich entlastung bei den
spritpreisen das könnte auch daran
liegen dass sie ampelkoalitionen sich
zwar darüber entlastung ist aber noch
nicht über den weg und es gibt aktuelle
meldungen von heute nachmittag das
geplante entlastungspaket
jetzt in den koalitionsausschuss gehen
soll man eine arbeitsgruppe aus
vertretern der ampel fraktionen seltene
30 keiner was ein haushalt in derart
schwierigen zeiten und bearbeitet werden
die finanzkrise das flüchtlingsdrama
seit drei jahren coroner nur ein
angriffskrieg im herzen europas
mittlerweile ist eine ganze generation
von jungen menschen in einem fast
permanenten krisen gefühl herangewachsen
sicherheit im wandel heißt wir als
deutsche bundestag haben die
verantwortung in dieser zeit
handlungsfähigkeit und stabilität zu
bewahren
wir zeigen nicht nur dass mit riesen
gewachsen sind und soll dadurch zur
ukraine stehen wir zeigen zugleich dass
wir dieses land trotz allem weiter
zukunftsfest machen wir setzen unsere
modernisierungs agenda und das ist im
übrigen auch ein freiheits versprechen
an dem herrn putin ablesen kann um was
es ein eigenes volk mit diesen krieg
betrügt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser haushalt ist noch geprägt von den
crooner folgen und er ist gleichzeitig
deutlich belastet von den erheblichen
auswirkungen des krieges die preise für
energie und nicht wo es für spritpreise
hörbar ist die preise für energie wohnen
mobilität für lebensmittel steigen teils
dramatisch mit noch nicht absehbaren
langzeitfolgen für den staat die
wirtschaft und die menschen klar ist der
staat kann nicht jedes risiko abfedern
oder ausgleichen aber es braucht jetzt
unterstützung insbesondere für menschen
mit kleineren einkommen und für
unternehmen die keine ausreichenden
reserven haben um den höheren
energiekosten standzuhalten wir müssen
aber auch sehr schnell die gierige
spekulationen an den ölmärkten in den
griff bekommen was da passiert ist in
hohem maße unanständig in unsozial
mein großer dank gilt dagegen den
bahnunternehmen und den zahlreichen
logistikern und spediteuren die den
kostenlosen transport von flüchtlingen
und die verteilung von hilfsgütern
stemmen sie machen die humanitäre hilfe
erst möglich diese viele menschen in
diesem land zeigen das ist der anstand
den die spekulanten nicht haben
meine damen und herren wir werden über
einige dinge im parlamentarischen
verfahren noch reden müssen aber bei
allen unwägbarkeiten und risiken löst
dieser haushalt das modernisierungs zu
sprechen der neuen koalition ein die
investitionen werden auf einen rekord
niveau verstetigt davon profitieren
insbesondere die verkehrs und die
digitale infrastruktur und wir lösen in
anspruch des koalitionsvertrages haben
indem wir mehr geld in die schiene als
in die straße investieren
zudem wird ein schwerpunkt auf sanierung
gelegt ich bin minister bissigen dankbar
dass er sich insbesondere des briten
themas zu engagiert angenommen hat
brücken sind die achillesferse unseres
verkehrssystems daher muss sanierung
oberster priorität partner
tja und wenn wir jetzt noch einen zahn
zulegen bei der planungs beschleunigung
dann können wir auch wirklich vorhanden
im koalitionsvertrag steht dazu fast
alles drin was man dafür brauchen dass
das kanzleramt die umsetzung steuert ist
gut noch besser wäre es wenn wir mit der
verabschiedung dieses haushalt ist auch
gleich ein großes beschleunigungs paket
mit beschließen könnten
aber liebe kollegen ungelegen allen wird
muss auch kritik folgen es gibt einige
notwendige nachbesserungen
der öffentliche personennahverkehr ist
im haushalt unterbelichtet damit den
ländern angestoßenen dialog zu mehr
transparenz qualität an einem besseren
angebot im öpnv muss schnell vorankommen
wir wollen mehr und besseren fallen
dafür werden bund länder und gemeinden
am ende auch mehr investieren müssen wir
müssen auch schon in diesem jahr mit
denen in rom wo energie preisen und
damit in diesem haushalt darauf achten
dass du den etv leistungsfähig erhalten
gleiches gilt schon im bahnverkehr wenn
wir die schiene im wettbewerb zur straße
stärken wollen müssen auch beim
güterverkehr die trassenpreise sinken
es bleibe ganz klar beim bebauungsplan
schiene habe wissen müssen wir die
finanzplanung mit dem deutschland- pakt
auch in einklang bringen es darf nicht
sein dass wir beim notwendigen
schienenausbau weiter zeit von st dazu
gehört im übrigen auch dass wir die
investition in die bahnhöfe steigern
müssen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der digitalbereich ist eines der
zentralen zukunftsfelder in allem riss
muss mit dem sondervermögen digitale
infrastruktur ist die umsetzung
zentraler vorhaben wieder in frage oder
auch der digital buck schule im haushalt
gut abgebildet ich möchte auch ich
sicher sein dass wir beim
breitbandausbau die notwendigen mittel
tatsächlich auch bereitstellen
umsetzungsprobleme können nicht der
grund sein für mittelkürzung ich erwarte
dass die programme ist so optimiert
werden dass eingeplante geld auch
tatsächlich abfließt und ich erwarte
dass sich digitale strategie mit eigenen
mitteln unterlegt und so ist es im
koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen
und ich gehe davon aus dass der
bundestag bereits bei der erarbeitung
der strategie durch das ministerium
frühzeitig zu eng eingebunden wird dass
wir am ende einen digital budget auf
zustimmen können liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen bei allen noch was unsere
darauf bei alten und zu schreiben hat
die bundesregierung angesichts der
aktuellen krisen einem guten
haushaltsentwurf vorgelegt meint damit
letzte satz
ist ein weiterer dank gestattet und
dieser stelle ein großer dank an vize
präsidentin göring eckardt und anfrage
vize-präsidentin paul wunsch angeht
es ist nun schon die zweite woche
sozusagen im schichtdienst mit
gegenseitiger ablösung bei den
plenarsitzungen und das alles allein zu
managen von früh bis spät verdient
großen respekt
der ganze bundestag denn tatsächlich ist
das bundestags presse bedanke ich mich
herzlich auch im nahen langkeit bedingt
ausgedünnt und schon in der vergangenen
woche haben tatsächlich katrin göring
eckardt und petra pau sich abgewechselt
über alle sitzungstage und zu zweit die
ganze sitzungswoche geleistet und die
geleitet und dieser haushaltslöcher
sieht den werther kolleginnen und
kollegen die politik sollte sich einmal
bei den autofahrern bedanken spüren sie
doch rund 50 milliarden euro jährlich in
die kassen und das ist in etwa so viel
wie das gesamte investitionsvolumen in
unserem haushaltsentwurf doch was
bekommt der bürger eigentlich dafür von
unserer regierungsbank schon seit jahren
ich sage es ihnen eidgenossen asphalt
liebe kollegen nur schweizer käse hat
mehr löcher als unsere straßen
8000 und damit jede zehnte
autobahnbrücke in deutschland ist ein
sanierungsfall allein in meiner
heimatregion hannover sind es 35
auch im flugverkehr wollen sie ihrer
staatlichen aufgaben nicht mehr
nachkommen
12 und 14 regionale flughäfen sind von
insolvenz bedroht egal ob straße schiene
luft oder wasserwege die lebensadern
unseres landes verfolgen die folgen sind
verheerend gemäss einer studie der kpmg
zweifeln ausländische unternehmen
zunehmend am wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland und fahren ihre
investitionen
kontinuierlich zurück grund ist neben
hoher steuerlast gigantischen
stromkosten die zunehmende schlechte
verkehrsinfrastruktur
den berichten zahlreicher kommission
zufolge ist unsere verkehrsinfrastruktur
chronisch unterfinanziert die
versprochene trendwende bleibt dem
aktuellen entwurf jedoch aus trotz
rekordneuverschuldung stehen in diesem
jahr für unsere straßen und schienen
knapp 4000 millionen euro weniger zur
verfügung als noch im vorjahr problem
ist aber nicht nur die chronische
unterfinanzierung sondern auch die
gewichtung der investitionssummen herr
minister sie planen tatsächlich in
diesem jahr mehr geld für die schiene
auszugeben als für die straße mein
kollege hat es bereits schon gesagt mit
der realität des verkehrsaufkommens hat
das wenig zu tun denn 80 prozent des
personenverkehrs und 74 des
güterverkehrs werden über die straße
abgewickelt
die die sie alle schröpfen sind auf das
auto angewiesen es sind pendler es sind
handwerker familien und senioren wer
soll aber ihre weltfremden mobilitäts
träume rot-grüner großstadt milieus
bezahlen wenn sie diese gruppen eins in
den ruin getrieben haben werden
mit dieser ideologischen politik
schränken sich aber nicht nur die
freiheit der bürger ein und sie
riskieren nicht nur den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
nein wer den verkehrssektor für öko
ideologische feldversuch missbraucht
gefährdet auch die sicherheit in diesen
häusern land in erinnerung an die
flutkatastrophe im aartal
und mit blick auf die kriegsfolgen in
der ukraine kann ich ihnen nur eines
sagen mit lasten fahrrädern kobolden
elektrorollern retten sie weder menschen
zuverlässig aus krisengebieten noch
erhalten der wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland meine damen und herren
krankenwagen und feuerwehren erreichen
vielerorts ihre einsatzziele gar nicht
mehr rechtzeitig weil sie sich an
künstlichen verkehrsberuhigungen wie pop
up radwegen entlang schlängeln müssen
damit muss endlich schluss sein was die
menschen in unserem land benötigen ist
ein verkehrswegeplan der straße
wasserweg schiene und luftfahrt
gleichermaßen einbindet sichert und
nicht gegeneinander ausspielt nur ein
optimales zusammenspiel aller
verkehrsmittel sorgt für eine
ökonomische und ökologische effiziente
beförderung von reisenden und gütern ev
lzh müssen gleichberechtigt behandelt
werden wollen wir die unabhängigkeit
deutschlands erreichen und wie lange
versprechen sie uns eigentlich schon den
bürokratieabbau
großprojekte dauernd immer länger
vielleicht sollten wir bürokraten
abbauen um damit die bürokratien spürbar
zu entlasten
ich tanke
[Applaus]
ich gebe stefan gelbhaar das wort für
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren haushalt ist
wahrheit das habe ich an dieser stelle
vor einigen jahren gesagt die wahrheit
ist im haushaltsentwurf 2022 sind dinge
die mir gut gefallen an anderen stellen
werden wir noch arbeiten müssen gut ist
der aus haid setzt auch die ab den
erhalt unserer infrastruktur wir stocken
nicht mehr wie die große koalition jahr
für jahr den neubau etr auf das ist
richtig so erhaltungs mittel sollen auch
nur noch für erhaltung genutzt werden
neubau mitte hingegen können auch für
sanierung genutzt werden das ist der
nordwind der notwendige
paradigmenwechsel den wir hier einleiten
erhalt vor neubau
das ist auch bitter nötig denn der
erhalt von straßen brücken wurde massiv
verschlammt bröckelnde brücken sind
übrigens auch eine form der verschuldung
und das problem gehen wir jetzt intensiv
an
moritz wendel das bedeutet verkehr
vermeiden verlagern dekarbonisierung bei
der dekarbonisierung verdoppeln wir die
mitte für die ladeinfrastruktur
damit wird die antriebs länder im
pkw-bereich angeschoben wir müssen
allerdings alle verkehrsmittel
betrachten und dazu werden wir dann im
parlamentarischen verfahren etwa bei der
e bus förderung genauer noch mal genau
hinschauen
warum
warum weil der verkehrshaushalt muss die
klimaziele von paris in den fokus nehmen
darauf haben wir uns als koalition
verständigt und dafür braucht es wie
verabredet mehr mittel für bahn und für
schiene und auch mehr mittel
immerhin und auch mehr mittel für einen
besseren öpnv mehr an digitalisierung
etwa durch bundesweite digitale titel
systeme das ist die richtung in die es
gehen muss mit dem klima und dem
transformations- von und dem regulären
verkehrshaushalt werden milliardensummen
dafür bereit gestellt dass sie das wir
hier konsequent in klimaschutz
investieren darum werden wir als
koalition gemeinsam im parlamentarischen
verfahren achten
die vision zero ist eine weitere
gemeinsame verkehrspolitische messlatte
in dem in den radverkehr style wären
soviele mitte investiert wie noch nie
das ist ein teil der lösung als
koalition haben wir beschlossen dass zu
verstetigen wir werden das
verkehrsministerium dabei unterstützen
eine effiziente und wirkungsvolle
verwendung dieser mittel noch in diesem
jahr zu organisieren
warum ist das so wichtig unter
verkehrsminister verkehrsminister
scheuer sind von jahr zu jahr immer
weniger radwege an bundesstraßen gebaut
wurden das muss sich jetzt ändern zur
wahrheit gehört der parameter das
parlament ist der haushaltsgesetzgeber
wir werden uns den regierungsentwurf
also selbstbewusst und kritisch ansehen
und dann mit unseren koalitionspartner
nach lösungen für die offenen punkte
suchen vielen dank
stefan gelbhaar war das für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und sie sehen
verehrte zuschauer wir haben auch einen
blick außerhalb der haushaltswoche auf
einen termin von bundeskanzler olaf
scholz der sich getroffen hat mit
roberta mit solarer präsidentin des
europäischen parlaments und werden dort
die pressekonferenz im kanzleramt
losgeht werden wir das auch kurz hin
schalten
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ohne eine nachhaltige mobilität wende
die diesen namen auch verdient wird es
nichts mit der einhaltung der klimaziele
der auto- und lkw-verkehr ist ein
zentraler bereich in dem sich die
co2-emissionen nicht reduziert haben das
ist unverantwortlich und muss sich
schnell ändern
ich habe hier noch erhebliche zweifel
dass das der ampel gelingt eine antriebs
länder ist noch lange keine nachhaltige
mobilität wenn dafür brauchen wir städte
und kommunen der kurzen wege
großzügige ausbau der fahrradwege
massive investitionen in den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr in stadt
und land der güterverkehr muss dringend
auf die schiene verlagert werden
all das wäre im übrigen noch sozial wenn
die ticket preise massiv reduziert oder
stufenweise kostenfrei würden dafür welt
fällt ihnen aber offensichtlich der mut
und auch der politische wille
wie anders ist ein sinkender verkehrs
etats uns zu erklären das mindeste wäre
es doch die summe der auslaufenden
corona unterstützung auf den etat
draufzuschlagen
dass die mandel dass die ampeln
schutzmantel dass die ampel mehr geld in
die bundesfernstraßen das ist die
wahrheit als in die bundesschienenwege
steckt ist absurd
und es müsste eigentlich völlig klar
sein dass die kommunen
gewaltige investitionsmittel benötigen
um den öpnv auszubauen attraktiver und
preisgünstiger zu machen gerade jetzt
bei den hohen spritpreisen die
ticketpreise zu halbieren wäre das
richtig richtige signal anstatt der
völlig verkorksten tanz stellen prämie
von herrn lindner
und wir könnten bei der verdoppelung des
öpnv noch hunderttausende arbeitsplätze
im industriellen bereich schaffen
nachhaltig sozial unsichere
arbeitsplätze das ist unsere konzeption
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
bernd riexinger war das für die linke
der sprecher für nachhaltige mobilität
der fraktion
[Applaus]
die pressekonferenz
rechtzeitig einschalten wenn es losgeht
mit 100 solar und
abschnitte sind dank sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin neun kolleginnen und
kollegen
viele von ihnen tun ist wie ich wir
pendeln nach berlin die sind
berufspendler und so tun wir es einer
stetig zahl da einer stetig steigenden
zahl von menschen in deutschland gleich
68 prozent der berufspendler in
deutschland nehmen aber das auto und
lediglich 4,6 prozent nehmen die bahn
das wollen wir im zuge der mobilitäts
wende doch eigentlich gerne ändern und
wenn man nicht schlagen würde wie ich
aus dem hohen norden von flensburg nach
berlin pendeln würde ich antworten mit
der bahn aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich muss ihnen heute ein
geheimnis reichten um pünktlich hier bei
ihnen in berlin sein zu können und um
eine kürzere reisezeit zu haben nehme
ich oft mein auto ja den verbrenner von
flensburg nach hamburg und steige dann
erst in die bahn und ich weiß dass
machen ganz viele berufspendler genauso
liebe bundesregierung lieber minister
wissing wenn sie die mobilitäts wenn die
wirklich voranbringen wollen dann sorgen
sie auch für eine zeitgemäße anbindung
für die teile der republik die außerhalb
der metropolregion liegen
hier sind schöne brücken und auch
bahnhöfe marode es mangelt an guten und
effizienten anbindung noch ein beispiel
aus meiner heimat der euro city zug aus
kopenhagen nach hamburg rauscht bei uns
vorbei der held nicht der fall waren es
an der grenze in flensburg das ist doch
unsinn
mit einer optimierten trassenplanung den
zweigleisigen ausbau und der
reaktivierung so wie elektrifizierung
von strecken ließe sich viel fahrtzeit
einsparen und ein zeitgemäßes
umweltfreundliches verkehrsnetz schaffen
auch in den randgebieten der republik
außerdem muss das nachtzug angebot in
europa ausgebaut worden und die dressen
trassenpreise müssen gesenkt werden hier
steht der bund in der verantwortung
die konferenz von olaf scholz und
roberta mit